well increasingly identity politics is
not a concern of the fringe left it is
the politics that dominates our national
conversation Elizabeth Warren
apologizing today to the Cherokee Nation
for taking a DNA test that's not allowed
anymore meanwhile ahead of issuing the
party's response to the State of the
Union address the 2018 Georgia
gubernatorial candidate Stacy Adams
Abrams rather has written an essay
demanding more identity politics in
American life what is identity politics
and is it good for us
Fox correspondent David Sun joins us
tonight well hey Tucker Elizabeth Warren
announced that she was gonna be running
for president putting an exploratory
committee out at the end of December
she's still in that exploratory phase
but making waves for these comments
about billionaire quote freeloaders
Warren appearing on CNBC yesterday said
she wants billionaires to pick up their
fair share
I want these billionaires to stop being
freeloaders I want them to pick up their
fair share asking for billionaires to
pay for more is not uncommon in politics
but calling them freeloaders garnered a
lot of attention this week Warren also
introduced in ultra millionaire tax for
those who have more than 50 million
dollars in the bank she also made
headlines this week for apologizing to
the Cherokee Nation for her DNA tests
that she took back in the fall for years
her native american ancestry claim has
followed her and that DNA test proved
that she did have Native American blood
but many many generations back the
Cherokee Nation released a statement
this week saying quote Senator Warren
has reached out to us and apologized to
the tribe we are encouraged by this
dialogue in understanding that being a
Cherokee Nation tribal citizen is rooted
in centuries of culture and laws not
through DNA tests now speaking of
identity politics as you mentioned
Tucker Stacey Abrams who ran for Georgia
governor she'll be delivering the
Democratic response to the State of the
Union on Tuesday and she wrote this
essay published in embracing identity
politics I want to show you what she
wrote she wrote instead Americans must
thoughtfully pursue and expand identity
conscious politics new vibrant noisy
voices represent the strongest tool to
manage the growing pains of
multicultural coexistence by embracing
identity and it's prickly uncomfortable
contours Americans will become more like
to grow as one now before the State of
the Union on Tuesday Abrams will be in a
Super Bowl ad on Sunday paid for by fair
fight action a democratic voting rights
group Tucker
Holy Smoke station will be following
thank you very much thank you